romantic love doesn't have to be between
a man and a woman the evolutionary
theory predicts that that's what makes
sense it just sort of fits neatly but
there's no inherent reason that a man
has to fall in love with a woman and a
woman with a man the same processes of
falling in love we find between gay
couples and straight couples and
bisexuals across the board so that's
important to point out and then along
the same lines as you're saying romantic
love varies enormously across cultures
what we imagine is romantic love
probably developed in French courts in
the seventeenth and eighteenth centuries
and this notion of that it's wrapped up
in love poetry and sort of the French
courtly troubadours and I would do
anything for my beloved most cultures
around the world that's very foreign
it's love is much more pragmatic in many
cultures around the world including
romantic love it is a necessity that we
live together it's a necessity that we
form a family it's a necessity that we
do all of these things so it's often
much more pragmatic in most cultures
around the world marriages are arranged
and we think of love and marriage what's
the Frank Sinatra song love and marriage
go together like a horse and carriage we
think of that as being natural and yet
in most societies around the world
marriage is arranged and for very good
reasons the arrangers would say my kids
don't know who to marry they're they're
too young they're you know they're being
guided by their hormones right now but
we older generation can see what the
best match for our children would be and
in those cases we can find romantic love
evolving after marriage very often we
also find in those cases people young
people who resist their parents arranged
marriages and really follow their heart
as we would say and so well our study
the study that we did several years back
looked at romantic love cross-culturally
the hypothesis of many of our colleagues
in anthropology is they
romantic love is confined to Europe and
to the United States and those those
cultures that have been influenced by us
and in other cultures we find arranged
marriages we find a much more pragmatic
approach and that really isn't romantic
love but we found that even in cultures
with very strict arranged marriage norms
for example we would find elopements we
would find suicides / unrequited love we
would find love poetry so even in these
cultures with very clear models of how
people should pair up there's a there's
evidence of romantic what we would see
is romantic love
and I would actually say in our own
culture probably our manifestations of
love are informed by Romeo and Juliet
and the latest movies we've seen at the
Cineplex and love poetry and so forth
and culture does even if there's a
biological basis for love and there
seems to be lots of good evidence that
there is something electrochemical going
on in the brain some of these same
chemical compounds are found in
chocolate and thus we have this folklore
about chocolate being the food of love
we can do MRIs and see particular neural
networks firing all of that can still be
going on but it's important not to
confuse a correlation of this brain
biology with causation that that's
making us fall in love our culture the
way we raised our upbringing our
cultural surroundings all of this is
what makes us fall in love in particular
kinds of ways the expectations of love
what do you do on Valentine's Day we
learned that you're supposed to give
chocolates and that you're supposed to
give roses we learn all of these things
and this is as an interesting aside we
can also learn not to love I mean
children who were brought up in
especially dysfunctional families are
often never form romantic bonds and
that's the tragic other side of this
one of the most fascinating among the
Trobriand Islanders uh young males will
pluck the eyebrows of their paramours or
their beloved's and this it's it recalls
in some ways and I don't want to compare
them to 228 but it does recall grooming
in some ways and grooming in chimpanzees
and gorillas is a powerful way of
creating a relationship between two
people uh but I love the plucking the
eyebrows the most fascinating ways are
that it's me it's mostly muted in other
cultures and you don't see the holding
hands you don't see you know smooching
in public and things like that